hey what's up guys my name is a Chan and
welcome back to my opengl series so
today we're going to be talking all
about errors last time we were able to
use index buffers and I even mentioned
one thing that you might do wrong that
would cause an arrow to appear and
actually does not display anything on
the screen check out that episode if you
haven't already but today we're gonna
figure out what we can do to actually be
notified or how we can find out what has
gone wrong with OpenGL when we do
something incorrectly that's a very big
part of OpenGL because open gel like a
lot of things tends to be fairly fragile
and we can upset it pretty easily that's
okay that's just a normal part of
development how do we know what we've
done wrong and how can we debug this as
quickly as possible and fix it so that
we don't have to spend the whole day
wondering why our screen is black okay
so there's a few ways to deal with this
we're not going to talk about using
external tools or anything like that
we're just going to talk today about
what OpenGL actually gives us as a way
of checking for errors and all of that
so basically right now we have two main
ways that we can check for errors in
OpenGL one of them is called GL get
error it's a function we can call it's
been in opengl since forever since the
very beginning and it's conserved
because that's compatible with all
versions and it works in a very simple
way basically whenever we call an open
shell function if an error were to occur
a flag kind of gets set internally in
open jails memory that basically says
what type of error occurred and when we
call GL get error that gives us back a
flag right and by flag I just mean like
an integer basically there's like an
error code and if we actually keep
calling GL get error it will kind of
give us all the flags because sometimes
it's possible for us to generate
multiple errors if you're really bad at
programming if you're really if you've
done something really bad you might even
have caused several different types of
errors with a single open jail function
call and so because of that jail get
error will actually set like maybe three
flags of three different types of errors
that have occurred and when you call
she'll get error it gives you one of the
flags just an arbitrary flag so you kind
of have to keep calling it to get all of
them but basically that's just us kind
of polling open GL us asking OpenGL hey
is everything okay have I caused any
errors now that strategy is okay the way
that it's typically set up is that since
pretty much any opengl function that we
call might
cause an arrow let's actually take a
look quickly at what an arrow might look
like and OpenGL to begin with so right
now since the last episode we have this
beautiful Blue Square rendering now what
I'm going to do is just close this and
inside my jail draw elements call which
is my actual draw call I'm going to
change this unsigned int enum which
specifies the type of index data that we
actually have to just say GL end this is
one of my favorite errors to demonstrate
because it's really simple I've made
this mistake plenty of times and is it's
fairly effective let's hit f5 you can
see that all we get is well a black
screen our square rectangle is just not
rendering at all and you can see that in
the console of course nothing gets
printed at all except for our OpenGL
version that we're printing we just get
a blacks we just get a black screen and
this absolutely sucks I mean I hate this
getting a black screen and then having
to figure out what you've actually done
wrong in which line meant like maybe you
maybe haven't set up your vertex data
correctly maybe your index buffers not
correct right maybe your shader doesn't
work like what has gone wrong it's very
hard to tell and in this case of course
we're just sending jail and instead of
jail unsigned and as the index buffer
data type so it would be great if we
could just get up and gel to tell us hey
man your GL draw elements function
you're passing an incorrect enum in
there you should fix that right that
would be fantastic
so the typical kind of workflow that we
have with GL get error is first of all
before it pretty much before every
function call that we give to OpenGL we
clear all the errors so we're basically
just called GL get error and a while
loop until it equals no error which
means that we've kind of retrieved every
possible error from OpenGL that's just a
way of that that's just a way for us to
actually clear all of the pending kind
of errors then we call GL draw elements
and then we call GL get error again and
that way we can kind of see has this
previous function called GL draw
elements has that generated any kind of
errors and if story which ones and then
we can kind of print that to the console
or something like that to figure out
what went wrong so that's one way of
dealing with errors in OpenGL it's
pretty much the most common way the most
popular way because it has been in the
specifications
one point one since the very beginning
and it's compatible obviously with
pretty much everything now recently in
opengl 4.3 so it is quite recent OpenGL
added a function that basically lets us
well it's called GL debug message
callback if we take a look at the
documentation real quick it's called GL
debug message callback you can see that
it's been added in opengl 4.3 and
basically what it is is it allows us to
specify a function pointer to opengl and
opengl will actually call that function
of ours when an error occurs now this is
much better than jail debt error because
first of all said of us having to
constantly ask her in jail hey are you
alright man is everything ok it will
tell us itself when something goes wrong
the only thing with this is obviously
the fact that it's in opengl 4.3 and
above so you can't use that in earlier
versions but also another really good
thing about this is it will actually
give you more detailed information
instead of just giving you an error code
which is kind of useful you like
completely useless they will even
suggest things like it'll explain to you
what you've done wrong in English like
it's amazing it's kind of dependent of
course on drivers and stuff like that
but in my experience that generally has
been very very good and much better than
jail get error today we're just gonna be
focusing on GL get era completely it's
gonna be just totally about you get era
that thought that way is still good and
it's obviously compatible with every
version of OpenGL but then in a future
episode I will I want to devote it like
a whole episode GLD about message
callback and talk about how we can
actually use that because it is much
better but obviously it's not really
compatible with every version network in
jail alright anyway let's talk more
about you'll get error so if I flip over
to the documentation here for GL get
error above and telling us of course
what it does and the fact that Jill nor
error is what it returns when we don't
have an error which you can see also
that Jill no error is guaranteed to be
zero so that's useful information here
it also tells us that calling it will
return an arbitrary error flag so not
necessarily all of the errors and
because of that we should call this in a
loop to make sure that all of the errors
are reset and we kind of get information
about all of the areas that have
actually occurred with OpenGL so that's
kind of like important information that
you definitely need to pay attention to
we should we should be calling this
inside a loop to make sure that we get
all of the errors because if you don't
kind of do that then maybe you might be
clearing an error just by calling GL get
error then you call a function and then
you get two errors back and you actually
didn't realize that Oh actually one of
them was from another function I called
early on because I didn't clear all of
the errors so just make sure you kind of
read this because the worst thing about
jail get error is if you can't even do
that properly and then you don't even
know what's happening all right so let's
look back to our code and let's actually
add all this so what I'm going to do at
the very top is make a function I'm
actually going to do this at the very
top I'm going to make a function static
void GL clear error and I'm kind of just
writing GL and capitals here at the
beginning of this function just to kind
of let ourselves know that it is kind of
an open GL internal kind of function
that we're writing you know and the
purpose of this function of course is
just declare all the errors so all we
really need to do is call GL get error
just like that and while that doesn't
equal zero so either the way you could
kind of write this is does not equal GL
nor error so while there while we
actually have an error back from opengl
let's kind of keep looping through this
so I'm just gonna add a semicolon here
and that's it we don't really need a
body we don't care about error codes at
this point in time we just want to clear
all the errors that's all now another
way you could write this obviously
because Jill no error is guaranteed to
be zero as we read earlier you could
just kind of write this like that
so while Jill get error is not zero then
keep kind of looping keep retrieving all
the errors but I am trying to keep this
code a little bit more clear for people
who are learning OpenGL so I'm just
going to write it like this okay cool so
we now have a way of clearing errors
let's write another function here which
will actually print an error that does
occur or all the errors that do occur
after a function call so I'm just going
to make this a void function called GL
check error or something like that and
all this is going to do is basically
what kind of the same thing is the other
function is going to GL get error
however instead of just kind of ignoring
this we're actually going to assign it
to something so GL get error as you know
returns a GL e Nome which is just an
unsigned int but because this is such a
close that kind of tied jail for I will
actually use GL enum here so while GL
enum error equals jail get errors I'm
assigning it here
some kind of retrieving the error and
assigning it to aro kind of all in one
line obviously since this is inside a
wild block this while loop will run as
long as GL get error as long as this
kind of error variable is not zero so
it's not false so while we kind of have
errors that we are actually retrieving
let's go ahead and just kind of print
them out to the console so I'm just
gonna write standard C out kind of
format this nicely
so maybe Open GL error and then in
brackets I guess we'll actually put that
error code and that's it for now all
right pretty cool so now we have a very
very simple way of actually checking to
see if we have an error let's let's just
test this out so I'm going to go down
here to my draw function now I have made
a mistake here right you can see I'm
using jail int and not unsigned and I've
still got that code in the first thing
I'm going to do is called GL clear error
write to clear all of errors and then
finally GL check error after the
function so you can kind of see how this
works we clear all the errors first to
make sure that we don't have any other
errors from other functions we then call
our actual function and then we check
errors that way we can kind of make sure
that all of the errors are actually
coming from this function and we're just
getting the errors from our last
function call alright so now let's just
hit f5 and see what happens okay look at
its check this out so in our rendering
loop we're actually getting a bunch of
pauses for SEC we're actually getting
opengl error printing and then 1280
fantastic so we've we know that we've
done something wrong and if we go back
to our documentation you can see the
following errors that we actually have
defined now which one of these is 1280
is the real question to figure that out
let's go ahead and actually go to our
OpenGL add a file so this will be in
blue for us if we type in 1280 when I'm
actually going to get anything because
OpenGL defines all of its emails in
hexadecimal notation so what we'll
actually have to do is convert that
error code from decimal into hacks to do
that I'm just going to take a breakpoint
into this error function here I'm going
to unselect this so that it resumes my
program you can see we have 1280 if I
just right click here I can go
accidental display and you can see the
error code is just 500 here in hex so if
I go back to my Glu header file and sort
and search for 500 maybe as 0 x0 at the
beginning you can see that here we have
all of our invalid kind of errors right
all of our error codes so 500 means
invalid email now at this point it will
be very wise for us to actually write a
function which translates these numbers
into actual words so basically if our
error code is Kjell invalid enum as it
is here maybe print invalid enum to the
actual screen that would be nice but I'm
not going to do that here just not to
waste time so you can see that our error
code here is invalid enum which tells us
that we've actually passed in an invalid
value into an OpenGL function and
specifically an invalid enum
now in this case that of course makes
sense because Jill int is the actual
invalid enum we've passed it should be
unsigned int you can see though that
there are a few flaws with the with what
we've done here and there's no I mean
it's not some of it's flawed it's just
it's not that great right I mean we know
we're getting an error we know it we can
kind of deduce that it is inside the
render loop and it's not you know in all
the kind of OpenGL initialization code
or anything like that that we did such
as creating our vertex or index buffer
because it's where we're getting error
is like every frame basically so we know
is something here right what we don't
know is actually which line of code it
occurred on so that's kind of an issue
and not only that but you can see the
code is a little bit clunky I mean if we
have to go back up here and basically
call clear error and check error before
every function like clear error and then
check out that's going to just pollute
our code and make it so much harder to
breed like why would we want any of that
that's going to just burden us with
error checking which we should be doing
just automatically all the time right so
there are a few ways of dealing with
this for our first problem it'd be nice
for us to know the line of code on which
this error actually occurred on now we
can kind of do that manually ourselves
if we kind of resume our program here so
it is running it is still kind of
spamming all this to the console I did
place a breakpoint here in this GL check
error function to figure out what kind
of value this wasn't hex you can see if
I look at the call stack I double click
over here I know that it's happened on
this line which is GL draw elements so I
do kind of know what line of code it
happened on however that involves me
placing a breakpoint and all that it's
not not too fun and also in this case we
kind of know what line it happened on
anyway because we're only checking one
function for errors but what we can
actually do is get our actual deep
to just pause execution and break on the
line that causes that error right and we
can do that by just using an assert
basically an assertion is when you
assert if something is true or false and
if that kind of condition is false you
typically like either write a message to
the console or just kind of stop
execution of the program and kind of
break on that line so it's kind of like
placing a breakpoint
but we can actually place a breakpoint
through code right we can actually tell
our kind of debugger hey if you run into
this line of code here into this
function that I'm calling break insert a
breakpoint here and just break right
it's pretty cool we're definitely gonna
talk more about assertions in the C++
series I'll have a link up there once
that video is made but let's take a look
at how we can actually do that so to do
that I'm just going to kind of rewrite
this check error function a little bit
I'm going to first of all get it to
return a boolean
let's just stop execution of that
program as well and I'll call this GL
log call okay because we'll add some
more features to it in a minute now if
this does return an error and in fact as
soon as it does I'm just going to call
return false here now you might kind of
question the validity of this loop now
why does this have to be in a while loop
if you're returning from the first
iteration but this is just kind of to
demonstrate from now so I don't really
care and then return true so basically
if we return false from this it means
that our GL pool was not successful I'm
then going to come up here and I'm
actually going to write a macro which is
our assertion
right so define assert X so all this is
going to do is validate a condition so
we'll have to write a like this if you
kind of write it like this it won't
really work because it's reasons we'll
have a video about C++ macros and all
that again I'll link it up there when
that's actually made but we have to
write our condition wrapped in
parentheses like this and if this was
false I'm just going to call a function
which will basically insert a breakpoint
at that and at that moment in code and
just break the debugger so this is an
intrinsic to your compiler which
basically means that this function that
you call here is going to be different
for each compiler that you're using when
I cover assertions in the C++ series I
will show what the function is for like
all compiles and all of that I'm sure
you can google it anyway but because
we're using Visual Studio here and this
isn't really about C++ is about OpenGL
I'm just going to use the MS BC function
which is underscore underscore debug
bridge
like that the honest colonoscope kind of
lets us know that is a compiler
intrinsic which means that it's specific
to M SVC and it won't work and clang or
GCC or any of those compilers okay so
that's pretty cool that's our session
function so what I can do now is
basically what we have this geo log call
over here at the bottom and this GL
check error will actually it's called a
log poll now let's just rename it to the
log call like that I can assert that so
I'll write assert and I'll wrap this in
parentheses like that and I'll hit f5 to
run my program so if this returns false
it should just break the debugger and
you can see look at that open children
AC has triggered a breakpoint on this
exact line we know exactly now a program
does not continue running and doesn't
keep spamming the error the error into
our console our console just reads Open
GL error 1280 and we can see where that
error occurred how cool is that much
better but we can do a lot better than
this the next step is actually going to
be just to get rid of having to call
clear error and then log call after
every function let's invent some kind of
macro that does that for us so if we go
up to the top where we define all of our
macros I'm going to define another one
called GL poll right X is going to be
the function essentially that we're
calling and over here the first thing
that I'm actually going to do is called
GL clear error to make sure that we
clear everything now I don't want to
write all this code on one line because
it'll be hard to read so I'm just going
to add a backslash and then hit enter
this basically ignores the newline
character so that we can continue
writing this macro on another line I'm
then going to just write X comma which
basically will insert that function
we've specified so that we call it and
again and on the backslash now one more
thing I have to mention is make sure
when you put the backslash you don't
insert a space and then enter otherwise
use you still got the newline character
there you have to put a backslash and
then with no spaces press ENTER and then
finally I'm just going to call GL log
call but this time actually inside in a
session so like this Jill log pull like
that and I'm not going to put like a
semicolon or anything over here because
we don't need to because after we call
Jill call we'll end it with a semicolon
all right so now let's scroll down to
our code here and instead of having to
call GL clear error and then asserting
that local what we can actually do is
just wrap this Jill draw elements with a
GL call just like that how cool is that
and now we can hit at five all right and
we get the same result here but you can
see now it's even more clear it's
actually on this Childre aliments line
so we know exactly what's gone wrong now
the what now one more thing we can
actually do is this error message
doesn't specify which file or line the
actual error occurred on we don't really
need that because we're running through
the debugger and it just breakpoints
right and it's easy for us to see what
file in line but if we're running it
without the debugger or anything like
that it would still be nice for the
console right to somehow print out the
file and line of code this actual error
happened on maybe even the function name
so let's see if we can do that let's go
back out of here and what I'm actually
going to do is make this jail lock Hall
accept some more parameters so we'll add
const char function which will be the
name of the function we tried to call
with all of its arguments and everything
well add const char file which will be
the c++ source file with a sack where
this function was actually called from
and then finally into the line so what
I'll do to this error is I'll add all of
those details so when we print our error
message I'll also add in the function
which will be just function I'll
actually move this down here so you guys
can see we'll add a space after that
function then we'll add file then maybe
a column like that and then the line of
code okay great so now we need to fill
all of that information in so inside
this GL local we can actually use macros
to figure out which file in line we call
this function from and not only that but
we can also since we are actually
passing in this function we can actually
turn in whatever X is into a string and
that's how we'll print our function name
and so to do that I'm just going to
write hash in front of X which turns it
into a string and then for the file its
underscore underscore file in all caps
now unlike the debug break this is not
an intrinsic it's it should be supported
by all compilers they don't worry about
that and then finally for the line again
it's just underscore underscore line
like that okay
pretty cool stuff let's try and run our
code again now when there's breaks if we
go back to our console check this out we
see GL draw elements with our actual
parameters your triangle six GL internal
pointer and then we actually have a full
path to this application or CPP source
file followed by the actual line of code
166 which you can see is line of credit
that breakpoint is on how cool is that
so we
exactly what's gone wrong where and what
we've actually like what what code we
actually tried to call that failed
because we're printing it all so the
console pretty cool stuff now well now I
know this is a lot to take in if you're
not familiar with C++ macros which is
why that video when it's ready will be
linked up there and all that and I
should do that probably very soon but
you can see with the power of C++ and
macros we can like really improve this
OpenGL debugging and specifically the
most useful feature here to be honest is
that actual debug break just being able
to break on that actual line by that
assertion that we've kind of created is
really really useful because it kind of
lets us know exactly where we've gone
wrong now what you should do now with
this GL call is actually pretty much
every opengl function we ever call so
like chill gen just everything we should
be wrapping that with GL call so
basically what I'm going to do here is
just do that really quickly every single
opengl function call so i surrounded in
GL call now because I wrote this macro
in a in a very simple kind of way there
are a few flaws for example if we use a
one-line if statement this isn't going
to work because just the first line is
going to be inside the if statement and
these true won't be and all of that you
can fix that by just throwing it this is
gopal and like a do-while 0 loop and all
that again I talked about that in the
macros video so kind of test so kind of
take this function of this code that
I've written here is just a really kind
of basic simple way of doing this also
putting it in a scope isn't very
preferable because if you actually have
values being assigned like if you have
the shader code that we wrote over here
you can see that calling GL career
program actually assigns it so we can
still do that inside GL call just make
sure you do it like this however the
issue is that if we were to wrap that in
a scope program would be out of scope
over here so if we were to kind of put
curly brackets like that around this to
keep it all in one scope then we have
the issue of of not really being able to
use program over here because it's like
if we're a program in a source code kind
of like that it wouldn't be accessible
anymore as you can see here so there are
a few kind of setbacks that we that you
have to be aware of and all that I'm
going to go ahead and add GL call to the
rest of all these functions that source
code is available for patrons if you
support the series we're going to patron
4/2 Cherno you will receive basically
the source code to every single episode
kind of episode by episode and that will
have all the story written of course
I'll do though I'm not gonna waste your
time and just you know write jail call
and every single function in front of
you because you kind of get the point
but anyway that is basically OpenGL
error checking right that's how I like
to do it I like to just wrap every
single function call every single OpenGL
function call inside GL call and
basically that will just break point and
whenever I have an error GL debug
message callback we will talk about in a
later episode because that is also very
useful and kind of theoretically means
we don't have to do all of this although
I find I still like doing this because
you do get the compatibility with
earlier versions of OpenGL and also
there's nothing really wrong with this
method it's just that GL debug message
callback doesn't give you more
information and is slightly more useful
and all that anyway hope you guys know
the video if you did you hear that like
button as I mentioned earlier you can
support this series by going to patient
icon for special journal and get some
pretty cool rewards finally we also have
a discourse server we can discuss this
episode and all of that the Turner home
safe discord is how you get an invite
there it's a really cool community where
you can actually talk about everything
you've seen this in this episode let me
know what you think about opengl
error-checking
or maybe if you have a really cool way
of actually checking errors that isn't
as cool as my way then definitely leave
a comment below or just in general what
you do to to to debugger OpenGL because
I know that it can be a huge issue and
that's why I'm not that's one of the
reasons why I'm not the biggest fan of
OpenGL anyway I'll see you guys in the
next video goodbye
[Music]